bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
émission exceptionnelle spécial
championnats du monde ce soir avec bien
entendu stéphane laborde pour présenter
cette émission est un invité surprise
stéphane puisqu'il s'agit il n'est pas
surprise d'ailleurs il est c'est l'un
des premiers grands maîtres français si
ce n'est le premier et il était prévu et
qu'il était prêt face à fait surprise
c'est olivier rault niveau soir olivier
soir à la rockhal
olivier rhône et donc tu es grand maître
international tu joues pour le club de
clichy et tu suis le champion du monde
sera comme nous alors quels sont tes
impressions depuis le début il
semblerait que
cette fois tous les favoris ou presque
non pas sont encore en cours alors qu au
dernier championnat du monde mais la
plupart avaient été éliminés donc à mon
avis les favoris cette fois sont
préparés et sont fin prêts pour ces
cadences rapides qui prennent vraiment
au sérieux maintenant et donc qu'elle
est en fait cette formule ne justifie
pas vraiment l'appellation championnat
du monde a priori on peut penser plutôt
à une coupe du monde
en tout cas pour des meilleurs joueurs
du monde ça a pas l'air spécialement
fiable mais peut-être qu'il serait
possible d'envisager comme on le voit
dans d'autres sports
une coupe du monde et un championnat du
monde voit la coupe du monde ça serait
ce type de tournoi très bien doté comme
qui permettent au joueur d'échecs que de
s'en sortir par le haut ce qui n'a pas
toujours été cas et puis d'avoir un
championnat du monde comme on l'a vu le
match kasparov cram n'est qu un autre
match un système de match qui dure sur
un mois mon avis on pourrait très bien
avoir les deux comme ça ça éviterait y
aura un vainqueur de la coupe du monde
les champions du monde bon alors on va
peut-être quand même annoncé des
résultats
oui oui puisque il ya eu déjà eu des
surprises pas trop mais il y en a eu
notamment la qualification de notre
français enfin est quasi français
vladislav tkachiev quasi et kanak quasi
kazakh effectivement puisqu'il est du
kazakhstan mais qui habite maintenant en
france
blaye savb chef a donc fait tomber la
tête de série numéro deux de ce
championnat morose et beach exploit oui
un exploit parce que manger faisait
partie des favoris et il a battu dans
les parties longues part dans les
départage ça c'est à noter aussi la
proprement battues alors on verra ça on
verra tout à l'heure effectivement ça
sera notre deuxième 2ème partie commenté
pour cette émission
la première ça sera une partie de shirov
puisque shirov lui aussi qualifié
donc résultat après ce quatrième tome
donc ces huitièmes de finale eh bien
nous avons donc encore ah non deux qui
s'est qualifiée facile en battant mais
siégea un ennemi un demi on a également
alors que je dise pas de bêtises le
khalife el khalife qui a battu leitao
très facilement sur le score de 1 1 me à
2 me cependant il s'est fait peur
alexander kalichman puisque dans la
deuxième partie du match celle où il y
avait des blancs et bien il a pris des
risques
et finalement c'est avec un petit peu
douteux voire même légèrement moins bien
pour lui
lighthouse voulu forcer les gains
probablement et a perdu donc l'état ou
éliminer le tombeur des français est
éliminé kalichman prouve bien qu'il est
venu là par hasard l'olivier kalichman
champion du monde l'année dernière
la grosse surprise ou est ce qu'on
savait depuis longtemps qu'il était très
très bon je crois que dans ce genre de
système il suffit pas d'être très bon
mais comme c'est des matches où la
plupart entre ils font deux nuls sur les
parties longues à peu près la moitié des
matchs se terminent pas retenu il faut
beaucoup beaucoup de nerfs sur les
parties rapides et bon apparemment
qualif panne fait partie des tous
meilleurs dans ce présent dans cette
cadence avec des nerfs d'acier on a vu
par exemple ils vendent chouk qui sur le
jeu est peut-être légèrement supérieur à
canif man mais qui dans les cadences
rapides kraft est capable de craquer
complètement
il ya d'ailleurs une anecdote puisque
contre eux et lgv est
au moment où il a il a fait une gaffe et
l'aurait poussé un cri lever sa chaise
le vsh est tout temps il écrasait la
chaise par terre de rage et qu'est ce
qu'il est la salle qu'est ce qui
l'aurait pas fait peur mais il agit là
ne se perd pas seulement il reste mais à
tous les autres joueurs qui étaient en
train de me souvenir à dire puisque je
viens de voir la igor nataf ce soir qui
m'a dit que au moment où ils vont en
tout cas a fait pousser son cri
il avait à ce moment là fait une grave
erreur contre short qu'il n'y a pas
coûté cher mais enfin bon voilà c'est
pour dire qu'il faut vraiment les nerfs
et ils vendent tout peut être à la fois
un joueur de génie mais par rapport à
kalichman il semblerait que il manque ce
côté ce côté nerfs effectivement quel
immeuble pour l'instant on n'a pas perdu
de parts il faut bien le faut bien le
dire il a gagné il en a gagné trois donc
il va à l'économie rick adelman
on les nomme et la partie par map mais
aussi bien des joueurs qui probablement
au niveau nerfs le plus solide que les
quotas il a battu les collations la
grande performance évidemment de bâcler
qu autant plus qu il avait pris une
sacrée raclée où on peut dire - en début
d'année ouais
et puis bon il a un titre à défendre
quand même
on dit toujours qu à munich champion du
monde mais aussi champion du monde de la
fidh et donc je pense que ça admet dans
des conditions de défendre son titre
encore plus plus motivé que l'année
dernière je pense
il est très très performant d'autant
plus que son dernier tournoi avant le
championnat du monde il avait fait le
score fabuleux de cinq ethnies sur six
au lendemain du tournoi devant judit
polgar tigana il ya un jeune encore ces
multi albert faim énorme perf à plus
3000 points elo donc très très motivés
alexander qualif mannella et bonbons
prochain tour il sera opposé à nantes
donc là tout est possible on y reviendra
en fin d'émission sur les appartements
du prochain tour également un autre
match c'était vesselin topalov contre
dryef très bon match topalov très beau
style d'atteindre idf l'école russe
topalov par la première il aime bien
raison il a bien tenté le tenter le tout
pour le tout à chaque fois il n'a pas
peur de perdre des partis parce qu'ici
qui peut en gagner beaucoup aussi
oui c'est ça en fait topalov c'est le
fameux joueur qui dit dans ce tournoi
j'ai terminé devant krainik alors qu'il
est deux points derrière pourquoi parce
que j'ai gagné trois parties l'une en a
gagné deux infectés vont ils comptent
pas les défaites qu'il a encaissés mais
il compte que les parties gagnées
topaloff
oui c'est comme ça qu'ils c'est comme ça
que j'y réfléchis donc il est très très
fort est effectivement ça a payé il est
revenu dans le match en gagnant la
deuxième partie et ensuite il a gagné
les semi rapide encore en se faisant
peur plus oui puisqu'elle a perdu la
première en semi rapide elle a regagné
la deuxième il faut dire quand même que
dans les parties langues
c'est très très difficile de gagner sur
une partie en fait les gens peut-être se
rendent pas toujours compte à quel point
ça peut être dur entre de niveau entre
deux heures de leur niveau de deux quand
y en a un qui veut vraiment faire nul 1
pour gagner faut s'accrocher donc en
deux parties il faut vraiment avoir les
nerfs pour remonter
oui rappelons quand même que tu as une
grosse expérience de ce gros niveau
puisque tu as secondes et anatoli karpov
oui c'était le match de championnat du
monde 93 9 90 118 ans de règne en france
deux parties une à new york une à lyon
bon ça c'était un match deux parties
dont l'offre là c'est pas du tout de
même système c'est le site mais on met
ses joueurs comme kasparov et karpov ont
des nerfs d'acier quoi c'est clair
puisque après je me souviens je peux
vous donner une anecdote je me souviens
qu'après avoir perdu une partie de
championnat du monde ne joue même pas du
tout affecté non là c'est impressionnant
pas du tout nerveux pas du tout affecté
très art combattre c'est très dur de se
mettre à recombine quoi mais
l'expérience car pauvre voilà à pisser
il a il a un style oscille à une nature
qui fait que c'est propice pour lui il
était chez qui fait bien parce que ça
tient film atteint l'art avec les nerfs
parce que là ça va devenir de plus en
plus chaud alors bon on va y venir
stéphane notre quatre chefs
effectivement venir pour l'instant fuit
la partie haute du tableau
il y avait un très très bon match
également entre deux joueurs surtout
michael adams michael adams gros favoris
avec des nerfs d'acier première fois en
finale contre allende deuxième fois en
demi finale contre
akopian si je dis pas de bêtises 1
oui c'est ça c'est ça donc adams très
habitué à ce genre de système coupe très
performant il joue contre celui de l'air
qui lui est un peu plus nerveux
peter zeidler le russe est donc adam
s'est imposé dans les semi rapide très
facilement très bien la passion et c'est
un des favoris adams donc oui il ya un
gros gros favoris même dans tous les
tournois en système coupe qui ont eu
lieu avant les championnats du monde
on est dans les tournois d'exhibition
qui a eu il est toujours été bien placé
c'est le seul joueur qui a battu
chronique depuis deux ans et oui en plus
celui qu'avait sortes etc ramener ce qui
est quand même pas mal et il a battu en
partie non où il avait battu en plus à
las vegas mais en plus il a rebattu
dernièrement en juillet à dortmund oui
c'est ça c'est la fin de ce parti que
craint un expert qui interrompt sa série
de sept et 90 partis sans défaite ou
quelque chose de cet ordre là pas mal
donc michael adams a gagné il est passé
il est passé au tour suivant il sera
opposé à topaloff
ils sont d'ailleurs tous de la même
génération à peu près adams call if my
way est lassé des joueurs quand
j'entends le savoir qui était connu pour
être un petit peu faire la fête tout ça
quand il avait 20 ans et ça fait deux
trois ans qui sont vraiment très sérieux
on a vu un calife man ultra sérieux
depuis deux trois ans même michael adams
et là ils sont en train de de percer et
de deux de passer facilement la barre
des 2700 on sent qu'ils sont au dessus
des autres quoi je me rappelle le
khalife magna quelques années
on était en coupe d'europe je ne sais
plus où je vois un calife man qui jouer
pour une équipe russe qui arrive devant
moi complètement bourré il faut devenir
complètement donc dans un état d'ébriété
total et qui essaient de m'empêcher de
passer alors j'ai pas compris pourquoi
mais bon il y avait des russes qui l'ont
attrapé qui vont mener la fin des russes
de son équipe dont qualif on avait une
tendance à voir beaucoup effectivement
il faut bien le dire et là il a tout
arrêté
il est revenu dans un rythme de vie
beaucoup plus sain et apparemment ça
marche ça marche très bien alors que
c'est un vrai sport mieux vaut mieux
être en flandre on a vu avec travnik
d'ailleurs la condition physique qui
tenait pendant un simultané moi qui ai
vu il ya deux ans j'étais carrément
impressionnant il en a perdu une dizaine
de petits loin c'est un véritable alors
on a donc un angle canif man ça doit
être le premier le premier quart de
finale oui ensuite on a parlé de dames
c'est la dame madoff alors quatre chefs
abattu mal rasé beach perdent donc une
très belle finale deux tours
les premières parties jouées scandinave
incroyable sacre est une pièce directe
gdi formule après dans une position très
compliqué éventuellement mieux pour blé
d'islam mais bon il à l'elysée tanzanien
trouve ça il restait une minute à chaque
joueur un ccsa donc c'était très très
chaud il a préféré faire nul les
deuxièmes il a gagné une très très belle
partie morges est vite joué peut-être un
petit peu léger donc quatre chaires
qualifié ensuite il y avait great choc
le phénomène d'ostende 17 ans personne
n'en a jamais entendu parler
pourtant il est très très fort très très
respecté il a gagné l'open de new york
je crois au premier ou deuxième
cette année laurent frayssinet a
toujours dit qu'il était extrêmement
fort
rappelons qu'il a le même âge que
etienne bacrot et ponomariov donc il est
très très jeune et là c'est le sol donc
le solde jeunes qui restent ici
ils étaient opposés à la lgv est et
laquelle ils ont d'ailleurs au club de
clichy prochaine
il a été contracté c'est une bonne
affaire en fallait davantage à l'est le
faire avant donc la 4f glitch look c'est
un copain de
igor nataf c'est la surprise si on
dirait c'est le quart de finale le plus
surprenant quoi oui alors nos valeurs
great zschokke donc pour bien préciser
qu'il était inattendu c'est le premier
le dernier joueur restant qui est arrivé
au premier tour certes tous les autres
les sept autres joueurs sont arrivés dès
le deuxième tour quel choc lui c'est un
peu comme à roland garros quand on a une
série de champion 10 hors des qualifs à
l'arraché qui a joué cinq matchs de plus
que tout le monde et qui continue en
quarts de finale demi-finales oui nos
classes et la grosse surprise
effectivement mcenroe son premier
masters de new york là je crois que
c'est bon alors là où il est arrivé en
finale en sortant des qualifs au seul
quart de finale en fait il n'y a pas de
de deux favoris il n'y a pas de top
puisque il y en a qui a éliminé ils ont
éliminé qui il voit une chaude canin
cadets ivantchouk sur son tableau où
elle n'a pas éliminé il a battu le
joueur qu'il ait qui a éliminé vente et
katia philippe par contre nature à la
rosée beach bon ils vont me dire quand
même quatre chez les favoris parce que
bon on a plus d'expérience et a priori
les plus forts aux parties rapides
mouais
donc a priori de catch est favori toute
façon on espère qu'il va passer après ça
devrait passer par la démission c'est
fantastique c'est super c'est étonnant
parce que à 17 ans quand même c'est une
sacrée pression s'étonnant qu'il arrive
à tenir aussi bien il doit être
sacrément fort et clair ni quelle
nationalité grichka et la russie ni
russes sont bien entendu russe il y
avait par ailleurs ou locaux
on peut pas trop parler de conflit des
générations le fait est que wilko été le
joueur le plus âgé à ce stade de la
compétition je crois qu'il allait doit
avoir 47 ans ou 50 357 143 championnat
des biens les années en 69 champion des
états unis et il a été chargé des états
est un symbole mais il a été un refuge
aux navires donc donc bull coup s'est
fait éliminer au cp / barrier fc fait
qu'il ya un score positif contre
kasparov d'ailleurs oui bon c'est vrai
mais avant qu'ils soient champions du
monde
voilà voilà c'est ça dernier match
dernier aux mariés vitrine donc bref
joue contre eux le vainqueur du match
guelph on shirov très beau match
effectivement très belles affiches
shirov on sait qu'il est pas forcément
très très stable dans ces matches en
deux parties de la forcément très à
l'aise on lit ça serait plutôt des
matches plus long donc nullement partie
longue et ensuite chercher à gagner un
an et demi en dominant ce miracle alors
notez que le favori du tableau hausse
était un an et favorite à blois c'est
chiant c'est ça c'est est morose et
beach c'était pour switch look la fidh
la fidh et a sorti un classement où
moore the beach était devant shirov
voilà juste une petite remarque barria c
le dernier survivant des seconds hand
oui oui vous écrasez les bars et f c'est
un joueur qu'on a et qui paie pas de
mine est en fait pas trop attention à
lui mais il a quand même terminé la pan
dans la coupe du monde encore les autres
il a terminé en finale donc barré a fait
très dangereux et très stable
oui mais très gérable et puis la télé
très fort bien sûr mais il est très
stable à toute la préparation de krabi
chronique du
lui apporter quelque chose oui mais en
même temps bon je me souviens que quand
j'ai secondes et karpov à prendre ni
complètement lessivé donc c'est assez
étonnant de le voir
aussi haut parce qu'il aurait pu craquer
on avait joué mais on était peut-être
tellement fatigué qu'il a un petit peu
par mois tape assez moyen bon donc oui
barnard et f attentivement la peine avec
un relation quand on le voit n'a pas la
carrure du champion mais effectivement
c'est peut-être un peu car c'est notre
carte à fond vous voyez quand même
plutôt petit il va forcer je suis là oui
je suis là présent un truc donc voilà
alors on va peut-être passer stéphane au
parti voilà on va essayer de passer au
boîtier tout ça je sais pas si on peut
voir les chics et oui on peut le voir
donc on va voir cette partie on a choisi
la partie d'entre eux schirrhoffen
quelle forme
c'est la deuxième du match scheer enfin
les blancs il a fait nul dans la
première et donc s'ils gagnent ils
passent le match et puis sinon que je
voulais semi-rapide effectivement voilà
c'est ça alors choisissez la et puis on
va voir aussi un petit peu après tout à
l'heure comment que kiev a réussi à
gagner contre rodez vite parce que ça
aussi c'était une belle finale deux
tours technique de l'olivier qui est un
spécialiste des finales au tour va se
faire un plaisir de nous éclairer donc
voilà donc là on voit
alors malheureusement les premières
cases à droite sont cachés chez celles
occupées oui
dakhla ici là alors donc shirov à les
blancs contre gilford et je vous le
premier plus l'homme qui n'a jamais
perdu en match
l'homme qui n'a jamais perdu un match
heroes points c'est vrai jamais perdu un
match deux parties longues voilà si
rapide le seigneur et lui donc j'ai
choisi de jouer avec eux quatre nous il
sait tout jouer shirov est extrêmement
fort et donc défendent qui choisit la
vente avec ses scènes qui s'appelle
dante la sicilienne voie la voie disait
tout à fait c'est une sicilienne alors
on n'est pas dans diagonale la leçon
effectivement si voulez plus
d'information sur la cécilienne vous
pouvez aller là bas avec notamment un
très beau très belle émission de
l'auberge est sur le combi mora le
compliment la varende qu'on vous
conseille à diagonale
éclatez vous avec la gambie mort mais
générant va soi commenté l'ouverture
stéphane sire offre choisi parmi moins
on peut dire que donc il n'a pas regardé
le leçon
oui et fêter alors il l'a regardé n'a
pas n'a pas été convaincue par l'oralité
convaincu mon alors qu'un grief 3 on a
déjà des concurrentes et cette ouverture
des six où il ya noté que galfond de
joux que la nage d'orves depuis depuis
des années les deux joueurs sont de la
même génération ils ont dû jouer 45
parties déjà ils doivent être un score
pratiquement lorsqu'on le gall s'est
vraiment
c'est presque du pile ou face
pratiquement et notamment cette
ouverture là qu'ils ont déjà joué de
nombreuses fois alors des quatre
poursuivants classique tu en prends
cavaliers prendront neige a commenté
plein de fois cavalier si ça tacle
appuyé le pion central calice et 3 on
développe les pièces et avantages ah si
ça y est on est dans la vanneuse la
défense nach der graaf
alors oui alors jean moi j'aime vraiment
demandé à olivier un avis sur l'idée de
ce coup à six le temps que j'y pense
alors
moi je jouais la neige dure depuis
toujours ça tombe bien assise d'abord
c'est un coût qui est toujours utile
dont joue un coût qui est toujours utile
le coût à 6 près par le contre-feu à la
dame avec bessin alors la différence
avec avec les autres sicilienne c'est
que ce coût à une plus grande
flexibilité
d'abord on ne donne pas encore l'adresse
du fou et fleet puisqu'on pourra parfois
joué j'ai six fours g7 nous le mettre en
chantier de le mettre en fouillant
kétohou éventuellement e5 qu'est
vraiment le coup de la neige dehors fou
e6 et on ne donne pas non plus la fin ne
donne pas la position du cavalier
levitte qui pourra aller en c6 ou en 17
donc on jouait en même temps un coup
très très très utiles et suivant le coût
que vont jouer des blancs et bien on
pourra choisir la réponse la plus
adéquate donc le maximum de souplesse
voit là par contre ça développe le pied
ça ça développe pas de pièces mais on
sait bien le nom à ccn c'est une partie
où les noirs prennent beaucoup de choses
dans le début ils sont souvent sous
développés donc c'est une lutte de
vitesse d'accord voilà donc
effectivement c'est à peu près l'idée
que je m'en étais fait c'est un coup
souple qui est très utile et très utile
avant deux ou trois ans d'histoire c'est
le quoi la mode
hélas beaucoup de possibilités kasparov
chaud les trois coups il a eu cinq alors
ça ressemble à laval 2 2 laurent
frayssinet ça non ça ressemble un peu à
l'avant il avait joué contre julie
pangar alors la bande de laurent
frayssinet oui mais c'est exactement ça
voilà c'est exactement la variante de
laurent frayssinet mans alors
effectivement c'est une âge d'or très
classique il y avait trois fois au cices
voilà un besoin pour dire qu'il faut
revoir les missions d'un victoire enfin
signer mon élément de sa partie contre 1
judit polgar dam des deux mais c'est la
même chose pour l'instant calais b 17 f3
alors là je crois que en fait ce qui est
à la mode ces deux jeux des cinq
maintenant pour pouvoir répondre à g4
par le dégagement de la case 17 ans je
manquais les b6 b9 estime alors ça c'est
ce qu'a utilisée a priori couramment en
ce moment mais là mon galfione qui est
évidemment bien au courant de ce qui se
passe j'ai choisi fawcett g4 donc j'ai
cassé alors l'idée aussi c'est de la
logique est donc évident c'est une
attaque aux sur le roi et a par contre
commis noir ont pas joué leurs cavaliers
17 si on joue gsm comment obliger le
cabinet sis à venir sur une mauvaise
qualité c'est à dire qu'on va l'attaquer
ce cavalier et puis il est obligé
d'aller sur la casaque tout simplement
et c'est ce qui va se passer donc petit
rock grand roque
à noter que les noirs n'ont pas
spécialement peur puisque la tacc
blanche et quand même pour l'instant
assez loin ces luges et 5 ça fait pas
une attaque
il suffit pas d'un tube qu'il fallait
deux pions les cavaliers son camp ça
permet de mettre le cavalier et 6 2 le
décentraliser l'enjeu et en même temps
on tape sur cette case des cinq qui qui
va être aux mains des blancs voient la
dame c7
alors coup a priori un peu curieux quand
même puisque comme on dit lecavalier
venir sur la caisse des 5 et donc on met
la dame sur une case où c'est à dire que
les noirs avaient échangé en d5 alors
c'est ça a priori on peut en déduire que
l'idée ça va être de prendre des cinq
rois bien bon ça c'est de ces
d'ouverture tout ça on croit bien sûr un
coût toujours utile de mettre le roi un
peu à l'abri dans le coin on va éviter
des échecs plus tard tours fc vite alors
j'allais noir masse des ddd pièce sur la
colline c'est avec l'idée éventuelle de
taper sur le pion ces deux oui je me
rappelle de cochonneries qui disait dans
la sicilienne si les blancs ne font pas
le grand roque
s'ils font que petit rock toutes les
variantes ou les blancs font petit rock
et bien ils vont perdre le temps ces
deux oui donc en fait un objet tout le
grand roque parce que le contrôle des
noirs sur la colonne s'est tellement
terrible avec la dame et la tour ou voir
même une tour tout seul mais que pour
dégager ce qui avait 17 mois puisqu'on
va bientôt obligés d'enlever un jour on
devra perdre le plan c 2 donc lavé le
roi ça protège un peu plus le pied en
voilà mais d'un autre côté on a mis
droit est ce qu'il vaut mieux de son
droit ses délires c'est un choix des
lectures yeux g5 et donc les
effectivement dégage la caisse dessin
qu'on dégage chicago f6 donc le qualifie
ce bien à chaque et maintenant qu'on n'a
qu'à se dessine qui est moins contrôlés
voilà à noter qu'on voit pas trop
comment les blancs peuvent continuer
leurs attaques
pourquoi parce que ce cavalier à chiens
qui est tout simplement à priori
indélogeable dire qu'on peut pas amener
le fou f1 pour l'attaqué puisque moi je
crois ils seront en prise ouais
en e2 ça ne sert à rien puisqu'elle
tient au restaurant
un plan qu'on peut envisager c'est
qu'elle et ses trois ans le 2 puis
angers 3 1 mais c'est vraiment trop long
donc ici de cavalia plus trop d' attaque
pour les blancs il faut c'est un village
center empêche les blancs de jouer par
exemple 1 h 4 h 5
même le deuxième plan en attaque ou
enlever un peu de deux flèches mais
effectivement ici bloc i blocks option
ils bloquent le pion majeur donc qu'elle
ait des saintes c'est l'idée de shirov
et donc c'est une bonne idée ça attaque
la dame la dame et ans et 7 il faut
prendre ce cavalier c'était prévu alors
à noter qu'on ne peut pas prendre
évidemment avec la dame d2 même si on
aimerait bien peut-être gardé la casse
des cinq libre pour des pièces puisque
l'option c'est de se retrouver en prise
avec les chèques avec échec donc
évidemment j'en prends donc là qu'est ce
qui s'est passé bien les blancs ont pris
la paire de fou et les noirs ont en fait
pour ainsi dire un pion des six qui
n'est plus faible puisque plus de casse
des singles salle a remis ça à l'air
simple donc sarko face à améliorer la
structure des noirs mais il ya la paire
de faux pour les ouailles de foucque
entre noël et puisqu'avec h5n1 peur je
dors à l'arrêt de tout ils bloquent mais
il est un peu hors jeu moi j'aime pas
trop un cardinal à bord et on dit qu'il
est c'est à dire qu'en fait c'est un des
thèmes stratégiques les plus importants
échec c'est à dire que mettre une pièce
hors jeu chez l'hôte s'est fait que
cette pièce qui est hors jeu elle
participe pas de l'autre côté
donc s'il se passe des choses adèle dame
ce cavalier à chaque c'est comme si
c'était une pièce en moins oui alors les
blancs le cavalier comme vous l'avez dit
bloc l'attaquent
et puis peut à tout moment allez sur la
case f4 voilà c'est fait c'est le seul
le seul avenir qu'il a pour s'échanger
éventuellement même au prix d'un pion
gagner les quinze morts mais la partie
suit des étangs on est en territoire
connu pour l'instant non pour aussi
qu'elle peut être enfin quelles peuvent
être les idées d'attac pour les noirs
comment ils peuvent développer leur jeu
puisque à priori les blancs maintenant
on voit des plans pour par exemple fois
h3g quatre mois j'ai amplement ça une
fois je travaille 24 ans attaquant la
carélie alors pour simplement à
affaiblir ce cavalier le forcer à bouger
dans dans une des parties
galfond n'avait joué cavalier b6 pour
justement pouvoir répondre à la foux h3
par le cavalier ces quatre là il a
rejoint alors je sens que sur fourrages
trois cavaliers c4 elle commence à
montrer ça alors là l'idée qu'on va le
voir couler d'accord voilà voilà alors
qu'elle chante joue cavalier des six
mois la mettez ainsi on joue
effectivement le couffo h3 va le montrer
eh bien je crois le métal ne vous
comprend le plus la casse et quatre en
amont triste occase cavalli b6 pourrait
sauter sur cette quasi s'y est attaqué à
la fois à la dame et le foudroie de
récupérer un fou oui tout à fait oui ça
c'est non mais c'est en plus un
gagnerait ces deux enfin de la riante
tout simplement
et puis ça libère lacazette 4 pour les
cavaliers enfin c'est génial quue tout à
fait à noter que la tour s'éviter
emprise mais c'est pas grave puisque
c'est les noirs qui ont ces eaux noires
de jouer tout simplement en voyant ça
comme ça c'est les noirs sont en avance
dans la variante convient de mentionner
donc fois je crois n'est pas possible
tout simplement dans cette position donc
maintenant le problème se retourne un
peu qu'est ce que font les blancs ici
alors ce serait une erreur bien sûr de
de prendre ce cavalier en v6 est un fou
et oui ce serait une grosse erreur parce
qu'on donnerait toutes les cases noires
et le cavalier est finalement là bas
complètement d'une part je place devrait
revenir sur une casse très importante
oui facile défendu par un pion et qui
peut plus être attaqué par un pion ni
par une foule à l'âme donc blanc très
difficile à contre attaquer oui
effectivement mais de toute façon
d'une manière générale ces données la
paire de fou fou qui ici est très bons
jalons d achever le jour j un engin oui
je crois dans une autre partie n'avait
joué cavalier à 5
oui avec l'idée justement de de pouvoir
jouer soit trois pour
simon contrôler cette caste qui est
bizarre parce que c'est quand même
galère aussi un peu à la borne est là
elf en avait même trouvé un très joli
coup cavaliers f 4 auprès d'un pion ils
sacrifient un pion et le fou pour un f4
puis on prend un f4 donc ça c'était la
partie donc voilà même et je crois qu'il
avait joué au lieu de dames pour un f4
il avait joué d'abord fou h3 pour éviter
d'avoir le moins ses missions ses deux
tours 8
enfin je trouve un tacle à tour il avait
joué tout revenu de tout simplement
et après
dan thouin f4 il s'était contenté de
fouet fuite
l'idée de jouer j'ai six fours g7 et au
prix d'un pion cette fois les noirs vont
comme dans un dragon pouvoir avoir des
très très belles cases noires oui
notamment on peut penser au plan comme
tuvalu à quatre mois la mairie casas et
les échecs moderne maintenant on donne
beaucoup plus facilement des pions
pour la dynamique et l'initiative du
goût du jour par kasparov
oui un fervent défenseur du jeu
dynamique et pêchue qu'ici peut être
déjà trois coups différents
la tour peut aller en g4 maintenant
aussi mais c'est une des idées ni ils
contrôlaient la casse et 4 voilà
contrôler les deux cases
il sait tour et peut être c'est un des
moyens d'activer une tour d'habitude on
prend les colonnes ouverte on les
comprend et les migrants déranger ou vlc
c'est plus rare moi si c'est plus rare
mais ici ce serait très efficace c'est
vrai que c'est tout ranger 14 mois ça va
se réduire un rayon d'action très très
bon pour aller en b 4 par exemple
attaquer cavaliers elle pourrait être
très dérangeante
alors là oui il se pose le problème pour
les noirs de trouver du jeu c'est
toujours le même problème
alors il aurait pu jouer qui a laissé 4
quand même ça c'est du moins ce qu'on
peut se poser c'est vrai ça al'air
possible qu'ils s'éclatent pourquoi pas
il aurait pu jouer cavalier ses cartes
mais un sucre le tête après les charges
les blancs sont content finalement de se
débarrasser de de ce cavalier de ce
cavalier c'est peut-être vrai tank g4g
câblage en gagne un temps peut-être
allez c'est pas tellement j'aime bien
cette position pour les noirs est
intéressant c'est qu'elle est
et une défense solide mon avis ce qui
est intéressant fait dans ceux des bus
et contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
croire les blancs attaquer les dames et
non pas le droit c'est à dire qu'en fait
pour des bus ont fait la menace
d'attaquer les droits mais une fois que
ce cavalier temps à 5
et bien on attaque de côté où il n'est
pas c'est le thème de la partie en fait
et du côté on a une majorité de sion
d'ailleurs d'une majorité sur les
marques à l'ancienne majorité de pièces
on voit que les piètres lecavalier b3 et
quand même beaucoup plus oui beaucoup
plus active de ce côté là alors il faut
résister souple il se pourrait que
sarsar passe de l'autre côté quand même
mais les parkings les plans sont plus au
centre et à l'est la dame pour l'instant
que lé droit d'accord remarque très
importantes au fisc et ne pas hésitez
encore donc là il choisit de jouer à 5 à
la fin un coup c'est pas mal ça enlève
la casa singh pour le cavalier on ne
sait jamais puisque ça a l'air d'être
une idée possible
et puis ça menace peut être à 4 à 3 pour
essayer le déloger ce cavalier
d'affaiblir laurent blanc c'est
clairement un moyen de trouver le trou
de l'activité saas et c'est sûr à 3 donc
ça c'est pour éviter que l'option noir
ni à vue m1 kotick mais que des
débutants oublie souvent de jouer et
alors qu'il pense pas un des petits
coups comme ça qui en fait mettre fin à
tout de suite au jeu des noirs quoi oui
puisque après à 4 effectivement qui a
été jouée par les noirs bon alors là on
peut penser qu'on est obligé de reculer
le cavalier voyons où c'est un mais de
toute façon le pion n'avancera plus et
ça sera pas facile à justifier ensuite
le jeu pour les noirs oui parce qu'il
faudrait famille l'autre pillant b mais
d'autres maisons mais de toute façon la
classe b 4 à les bloquer s'était pas
puisque à l'option et adam la dame mais
également la tour qui veut venir de
toute façon il ya plus jazzy et le
client à la fin du tour être dont à long
terme une faiblesse oui par finale il va
difficile à défendre
effectivement il a bien avancé avec en
blanc donc qui peut être attaquer
facilement et là de toute façon chez
rough il avait eu une idée il y avait eu
une idée validée il a vu il ya vu un
coup sympathique assez exceptionnel donc
puisqu'il choisit donc oui c'est ça le
savonnage airbus il ya une congère enfin
shirov en fait tu as envie de mettre ces
pièces sur des cases alors qu'elles
soient prises ou pas en fait c'est pas
son problème est effectivement il
convient dé sa pièce en prison voilà
c'est dit mais quand même c'est cette
c'est ça qui est beau c'est qu'ils se
dirigent quand même vers la case effet
aucune menace aux cavaliers nous tenir
en mai il fait simplement une menace
stratégique c'est qu'il veut se diriger
vers cette case
car travail parce que là il est très
bien passé mais magnifique pour ce
cavalier un cavalier pause plos placé
hors cadre dans cette position est
magnifique ce qu'il est qu à ce qu'il
n'aurait pas pu à nous il n'aurait pas
pu aller s'il était bêtement allait
lancer un moyen son côté l'ont donc
hilali en même temps la tactique et la
stratégie là c'est vraiment l'essence
même du jeu mais tout à fait ou a noté
qu'il y avait eu de se gaver de roccat
est trop trop fantastique puisqu'il
permet d'aller et sur le roi de temps en
temps et en même temps il soutient
d'avancé du pion c4 c5 pour tout cas
c'est donc et c5 très fort gamme ford
bon s'est dit qu'est ce qui se passe
mais a priori je pense pas qu'il était
préparé à ce coup là oui parce qu'il est
pas obligé de prendre il est obligé de
prendre non puisque effectivement c'est
une menace positionnelle donc a priori
toujours supportable dans une certaine
mesure il a pris le cavalier bon
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas ça à l'air de
rien quand une pièce est en prison va
d'abord la prendre et on me fait chier
après on peut faire ça mais ça se fête
derrien ses compères un programme sur
les combinaisons il ya un proverbe
les russies disent qu'en boîte vinik
sacrifie une pièce des fois faut prendre
des fois faut pas prendre
quant à elle sacrifie une pièce faut
toujours prendre et quand petrossian
sacrifier une pièce il faut abandonner
oui oui parce que les tensions se crier
jamais donc si ça te dit c'était que
vraiment il y avait de très bonnes
heures de samedi
c'est un peu surface mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai que quand shirov sacrifie une
pièce c'est un peu de la routine quoi
pour moi j'ai pas combien de pièces il a
sacrifié par parties devraient faire des
statistiques mais la plus belle partie
ça restera quand même celle contre
topalov que vous pouvez retrouver dans
les archives on essaie de recycler nos
archives mais effectivement dans les
spéciales sarajevo ouais il y avait une
partie complètement fabuleuse la partie
topalov noir shiro blanc shirov qui a
donc plein de pièces en brise et qui
jouent tranquillement roi bien oui on
comprend pas ce qu'il veut faire
ensuite il nous faut deux mettant le fou
en prison mais alors on comprend
toujours pas ce qu'il veut faire et
ensuite c'est seulement plus tard qu'on
comprend ce qui se passe oui elle est
très très belle effectivement il met
toujours toutes ces pièces emprise bon
alors là il ya quand même justification
très simple pour ce qui est de ce cas
précis c'est la fourchette voire la
prochaine tout de suite fait on joue
donc on avance le pion d'un thème qu'a
dû être mis dans lesquelles les petits
cahiers ou de diagonale oui oui la
fourchette moyenne
comment la mission tout à fait attaque
dame est fou donc ça récupère la pièce
au prix d'un pion quand le prix d'un
pion effet confiant puisque la bourse
acquis un bien fou prend 2,6 alors à
noter qu'il a pris le fou donc ils
échangent et en fait son cavalier
contrat fou donc on peut se demander
quelle peut être l'idée on va voir à
l'idée c'est pas simple avoir un comme
dame 3d si ça me prendrait si on se dit
bon mais
1.1 purement quoi c'est quoi l'idée est
bien sûr moins bon alors effectivement
la compensation on en voit assez vite
beaucoup
déjà premier point la peur de fou voilà
on a tout faux avec les blancs contre
odos cavaliers ça c'est plus fort une
position très ouverte
deuxième point les pions noirs ressemble
pas à grand chose on voit par exemple le
cuir en a quatre qui est faible va
s'avérer une faiblesse puisque on est on
est déjà en finale là on peut dire que
les dames vont s'échanger l'option c5
qui est déjà attaqué le pion aux 5
aussi et en même temps la position du
roi noir en finale elle n'est pas à mon
avis ni pas terrible comparé à celle de
roybon enfin ça c'est un avis qui peut
se discuter mais en tout cas il ya
directement des compensations ouais
et puis alors là il ya un point sensible
c'est le cavalier b6 faire une lessive
waikiki c'est le point sensible parce
que ce cavalier est très instable mais
peut pas bouger du tout et en plus voilà
il n'est pas défendu par exemple en cas
d échange des dames qu'est-ce qui se
passerait on peut voir tout de suite
d'un défensive parce qu on serait
content d'échanger les dames avec un
pilote plus mais on rentre attaque le
cavalier qui a pas de point d'appui il
n'y a pas de case le seul coup dans
cette position ses tours ses 6 ouais
puisque tours à 6 effectivement c'est
interdit par le fonds f1 il faut être
fou on attaque la lgo lointain fait une
tour celle-ci s'est forcé et là on peut
supposer qu'on échange les tours
pourtant tour et après qu'on prend
directement on récupère notions
occupèrent le pion avec une paire nos
fous des pions noirs faible ou une
position probablement techniquement
gagnante
alors là en tout cas avec gros avantage
qu'on avait à vendre aux avantages pour
ça qu'on a longtemps pour que les
cavaliers soit fort il faut qu'ils aient
des points d'appui donc là la limite ce
cavalier lota un point d'appui en f4
c'est peut-être mieux c'est peut-être ce
qu'il aurait dû faire c'est peut-être ce
qu'il aurait dû faire et ont comparé à
la partie bien sûr oui tout à fait c'est
vrai qu'en valeur la partie
les noces ça va très vite même si c'est
pas extraordinaire pour les là on peut
se dire que les noirs tiennent
facilement en mettant leurs cavaliers
sur les deux casses verte
mais bon y'en a une qui est pas stable
une année majeure la thèse des cinq
combats avec n'est pas stable puisqu'il
peut être attaqué par un pion donc de
toute façon ça va être une longue
torture les fous qui vont gigoter dans
tous les sens ça va pas être facile à
venir c'est un peu spécial mais en tout
cas et le gaf 1
à trouver pire oui il a trouvé tir
trouve effectivement joué un coup qui
paraît logique de se fermer son commerce
le cavalier qui depuis n'a pas l'air
mauvais mais ils enlèvent flash 3 au
passage il empêche fois je crois qu'ils
pouvaient être une menace
bon au passage puisque un livre
peut-être mais n'a ni là je pense que
maintenant il veut jouer dame prendra
mais peut-être éventuellement qui veut
dire qu'elle est un des 5 voilà ça sert
est une des idées non il peut pas le
favori dans les palais par l'armée après
tour c6 voilà donc ici voilà l'idée de
kb24 salaire très sain mais maintenant
c'est mathématiquement je crois qu'on
peut le dire mathématiquement perdre on
dirait pas comme ça surtout avec les
coacher va jouer ouais il commence par
une binette cavaliers pour éviter que le
cavalier b6 puisse aller à un dessin
unique de feuillus vraiment eu escalier
b 6 j'en prends tu me prends et à fonder
5 1 aux curieux c'est magnifique et
l'idée l'idée c'est de prendre des cases
aux cavaliers c'est ça non c'est de
développer les pièces développées les
pilotes il veut ramener la tour g1 a eu
un ouais ça c'est la première idée
l'autre idée c'est effectivement que ça
contrôler la case 17
ça peut être bon dans certains cas et
ils contrôlent la place et si ceux ci
restent et les voilà rien n'empêche la
tour sans fin pour ça vite devenir
protéger le cavalier un peu bêtement
très ce qui se passe sur les changes des
dames maintenant parce que cela a cessé
ses terres et voilà sont les changer
d'armes perd tout de suite mal à masquer
à la tour prend hélas avec un malien
popul défendre oui c'est ça puisque le
fou donc contrôler la dren qualité ce
qui avait un autre
les deux cases donc là cavalier pas de
case on peux pas le défendre on peut pas
attaquer à autre chose il ya plus de
solutions et plus de solutions on ne
peut pas jouer et d'apprendre à ses
remarquables comme il est un oui les
doigts c'est remarquable est ce qu'en
fait il a commencé à jouer sur un
cavalier h5 est malin il joue sur un
cavalier en b 6 mais c'est assez rare
qu'on puisse jouer sur un cavalier comme
ça que pas très avancé ouais c'est comme
ça on vous ça paye pas de mine comme ça
alors autres barrages
c'est nathalie renard cas tout à fait
autre variante effectivement on peut se
dire je vais chasser le fou ce fou et
ennuyeux je vais jouer tour à 5
oui a priori pourquoi pas moi ça a l'air
de sa liberté à vide pour la réaliser un
problème il ya un problème grave
effectivement ça libère sa pièce la ja
d'apprendre à me prendre et et donner
d'autres points dames certes à la
réfutation la réputation tour des huit
matt va couloir fouloir est tout à fait
humain d'ivoire aeci qu'avec le roi qui
ne peut pas sortir
voilà donc tout simplement beaucoup de
problèmes à 2,56 à l'attaqué donc reste
néanmoins un coût pour tenir donc el
fouara des gones en nba les matins une
goutte d'alcool l on aime bien les
batteurs un coup c'est vrai on les
montre systématiquement le seul coup
effectivement olivier thual est
mentionné tout à l'heure c'est tout
rabais mythe
brad et 8 pour libérer la casse à 8 pour
le quartier mais c'est triste c'est très
triste
bah c'est même affreux de toute façon et
en plus les tours vont rentrer les
blancs vont rentrer dans leur parce
qu'on veut tous recettes c'est ça on va
jouer tout d'abord et après tu es pierre
et on va rentrer en bo7 on va rentrer
les deux tours on le 7 et 17 on va
remettre le fou sur les quatre c4 et
puis on va prendre le père de saad
mais on prend tous les pions de tokyo et
câlins et tous les plans on va se
régaler donc la balle là c'est terminé
tout simplement guelph on ne trouve pas
il joue g6 peut-être avec l'idée de
tétouan 5 live du millénaire du vin voir
maintenant changer les dames
toujours pas toujours pas mais il veut
éviter le mal du coup le racing peut
être avec l'idée tout racing après oui
oui au c4 attention c'est pas un coupon
de spécialement with you et we en
flamand de toute façon tous rejettent en
un voile à tour gérer un très fort on
centralise la bonnasse maintenant c'est
clairement tours sète on veut forcer la
dame noire et bien prendre tu vois si
les nombreuses lignes et qui avait duré
six mois le mans il ya plus de solutions
et droit syndical s'est joué des
concerts dans ces sommes qui dormaient
pugilat pied jusqu'à valises à 6 fois il
est allé chercher quoi il va le chercher
dans le cas de versailles
il va chercher après tour à cinq il ya
une petite combinaison extrêmement
triage donc faites vous la main vous
avez quelques instants pour bien
regarder les blancs jouent et gagnent en
fait tous mes fans trivial trivial c'est
chez rough qui jouent contre glen forme
comme oui mais il n'empêche
n'empêche que c'est vrai qu'il est allé
est trouvable combinaison trouvable
trouvable d'ailleurs il s'agit de tours
8 échecs boom surprenant deux
possibilités un leroy et échec
donc soit on joue tour à tour soit
montres leroy alors si on monte le roi
surmonte le roi c'est treignac le fameux
maton un baiser de la mort coda 9,6
échec et mat
le baiser de la mort la dame embrasse le
roi et le roi ne peut pas par se sortir
oui à notre expertise et de la mort pure
donc c'est quand même un baiser de la
mort
ouais vicieux comme elvis stojko vision
et de nos puisque latour laguens rôle
des trois cases ici l'option pour trouve
cette case là le reste occupée par des
tons noir c'est un petit baiser de côté
petit baiser tranquille reste donc la
seule possibilité de jouer le tour prend
tout ce qu'un fusible une fin ce café
galfond d'après d'amsterdam n'avaient
plus défendu la dame nous avons gagné la
dame
cependant on a déjà donné un tour il ya
encore un fois aux prises donc les noirs
prennent aux fous ouais très logique et
maintenant elle a ajouté qu'il aurait pu
jouer d'abord il aurait abandonné
oui il abandonne maintenant puisque
après de celle ci c'est bien la tour b5
et b6 vont moins de 500 williams on
associe peut-être tour ton dès 6 ans
ferme en tout cas il est très rare de
gagner c'est terminé nous pour résumer
cette partie qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
dire l'idée à 5 à 4 après l'air d'être
exempt vous ferrez fêter parce que sur 1
4 il n'avait peut-être pas prévu qu'à et
c5
oui si stratégiquement en fait pose des
problèmes énormes puisque s'il s'y prend
il est très mal comme on l'a vu
et s'il prend pas il est aussi très mal
parce que cavalier bien sûr cat et la
partie extrêmement difficile à cause du
cavaliere bon alors noté cité des
parties rapides oui voilà par les
arbitres comme d'une bonne qualité
puisque on voit que même en partie
rapide les joueurs arrivent pas et faire
des partis qui soutiennent ouais du
début à la fin c'est dire qu'on voit on
voit un plan clair on voit des variantes
tactiques assez clair et sans trop
d'erreurs donc c'est quand même des
partis assez instructive je dirais wayne
d'autant plus que les quelques erreurs
ce qui fait ce qui met bien en avant la
force de shirov en l'occurrence gros
favoris aussi dont on sait qu'il est
très fort en partie rapide puisqu'il a
gagné le landau grand prix de bordeaux
et les grands pays du cèdre malades
comme une famine et les deux alors on va
voir maintenant froid on a eu nous reste
du temps et heureusement parce qu'on va
quand même jeter un petit coup d'oeil
selliti de quatre sièges mais cocorico
donc ouais d'accord ecall contrôler mon
rendez vite on ne pouvait pas tout la
commande et parce qu'elle est trop
longue mais on va je crois qu'on va
s'attarder à la finale je pense oui la
finale deux tours
alors j'essaie de récupérer cette partie
déjà la première partie était déjà
complètement
délirante puisqu'il avait donné une
pièce d'habitude c'est une rosée vite ce
qui donne des pièces
voilà je le lait la partie de la liste
rav4 je déroule les coûts et oui je
déroule les coudes
je pense même qu'on peut passer
directement à la fin parce que là ça va
sûrement pas la vidéo donc non ça se
faire un pas mais je lui demande quand
même d'accord donc si nous déroulons les
coûts voilà en direct reste un pion là
ici on va noter quand même au 16e coup
oui c'est alors à noter que seymour
savic qui a sacrifié la placer des pions
il a sacrifié quatre chefs le prend oui
donc là parce que l'on vient de voir un
sacrifice d'options de shirov qui était
bien voilà c'est un sacrifice de moments
délicats qui n'est pas bien qui n'est
pas bien parce que lundi cela va
s'accrocher moyens sans pian et il va
réussir à noter que le gros problème
alors si puisqu'on aurait puisqu'on est
en train d'en parler c'est que le fou g7
est jamais bon dans ce genre de
structure c'est à dire quand c'est comme
ça on préfère mettre le fou est
évidemment sur la case e set
ouais parce que l'asie continue à
exercer une action de ce côté là quand
il est aux anges et 7eme il bute sur le
plan des quatre saisons
tout ça c'est très alors on va continuer
alors ladislav kashef arrive à tenir son
pion on passe sur les détails techniques
et à échanger des pièces
oui donc là les dames sont échangées ou
27e coup il m'a dit c'est que maintenant
que des actions isolées pour les douars
au passage il est obligé de jouer sa
bourse et vite jeu pour faire jouer son
fou g7 et il va transformer la ils
échangent encore des pièces là on est au
37e coup il a réussi à changer pas mal
de pièces il ya plus qu fou quand
cavaliers et toujours ce fans obtiennent
plus ici en b 5
mais bon c'est pas si facile que ça à
transformer en opposition avec le ciel
du tout que 9,5 surtout que morose
évident je vais essayer de jouer les
finales de tours qui sont souvent nul là
la perspective de food et blanc voilà
elle est clair c'est de se faire
échanger
alors attention stéphane on va revenir
là c'est très intéressant la façon dont
reprendre le foot est roi alors donc bon
le lycée au 40e coup voilà le fond est
dominé par cavalier faut bien le lien on
voit mal comment ce fou pour se replacer
sans laisser par exemple qu'à les
prendre l'option c'est dire si on essaie
peut-être trouver un passage alambiqué
par odin c'est les noirs qui vont
ramasser espions tout de suite ça va pas
ouais donc quatrièmes jeux fou g3 avec
l'idée que ce fou aux tacles
voilà tour ici en b vite donc avec une
variante voyez petites jambes si on
prend en d4 mêlée ça permet qu'un valet
tout petit sa peur tout de suite c'est
pour le cac manitou et cinq échecs faut
cinq échecs gagne le cavaly moi je
pensais plutôt ont fait eux aussi font
rire mais glycogène voir gagner une tour
promet lui de soucis qui dit mieux
donc qu'ils peuvent vraiment pas prendre
le coeur qu'elle est proche et 3 c'est
logique
voilà et là se pose donc le problème on
est dans une finale deux tours puisque
les blues vont reprendre son cavalier
soit avec le roi soit l'option comment
reprendre mais on dit souvent qu'il faut
comprendre l'un des pions parce que dans
ce cas là parce que le pian on se
rapproche du centre employés on prend
nos pions h qui se rapprocherait du
centre mais non en fait vladimir choisit
d'activer son rang vous des prix avec le
roi donc effectivement ça se discute
peut-être qu'après pions pranger 3 il
peut jouer h5 pour fixer la structure et
c'est pas si simple pousser ses pions
qui en plus le plan jitrois peut être
attaquables après par une tour 1
alors donc ça c'est très intéressant
après psion projet 3 et puis peut-être
tout simplement le roi blanc a du mal à
s'activer
il voudrait faire j'ai quatre nous de le
redire 3 mai après 5
c'était là il ya une règle on peut dire
peut-être olivier c'est que il faut pas
changé toujours avec les blancs plus on
est champion ce rapprochement voilà
et d'un autre côté quand on a des filles
en moins c'est pas toujours valable mais
je veux - ja pions sur l'échiquier du
nos chances augmentent
oui c'est pas une règle tout à fait
toujours valable mais quand même
la simplification permet souvent de
faire nul donc a priori il a pris avec
le roi dix ans pour laisser les pions
comme ça face à face donc pas de risque
des changes est d'autant plus que le roi
arrive sur la salle cazelles 4 oui très
actif près du centre et alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que si avec une seul
tour au lieu de deux ce serait
évidemment complètement gagné oui ce
serait très facile parce que à ce moment
là on aurait la tourbe évite qu'ils
seraient totalement paralysé alors que
là il ya la tourbe évident qui est
paralysé mais la tour des vis tu peux
attaquer bessette et finalement les
tours blanches ne sont pas complètement
libre ouais c'est ça c'est aussi coincé
voilà il ya un peu de liberté pour la
liberté grâce à la tour et la
possibilité d'attaquer deux fois le pion
donc cette finale à deux tours et quand
même malgré ce pion 17 qui est très très
très dangereux assez difficile à gagner
donc il faudrait que
lundi cela arrive à échanger une tour en
fait pour soi il arrive à échanger une
tour soit ils arrivent à pénétrer avec
son roi allèles dames où lé droit il a
gagné un autre pion alors on il nous
reste plus beaucoup de temps puisque on
a aussi les marges arrière a commenté
donc on va regarder la technique
française a pris 13 alors à noter deux
projets six ans relève qu'après ce cap
donc là tout cette trilogie est prévue
les 6 donc là il fait d une barricade
contre le droit d'activer son roi
m'indiffère sont vraiment tout est
contrôlé il peut pas faire mieux avec
son or c'est difficile parce que si il
chasse le roi avec sa tour le roi s'en
va et on doit revenir avec la tour parce
que le pion bessette est toujours sous
pression
comment faire maintenant un tel tour b6
pour avancer un peu on l'a tourné si
c'est ce qui le fait que gagner par zig
zag cette position seulement maintenant
que ça veut dire qu'on peut plus bouger
est ce que je demande en fait c'est
assez bizarre c'est un petit peu comme
au snooker
ça veut dire qu'on met l'autre dans une
position où il aimerait ne pas jouer
mais il est obligé de jouer et tous ces
coups s'opposerait coin comme nous c'est
le snooker ça va on s'est menti met les
boules derrière finlande si vous n'êtes
pas beaucoup de temps on va peut-être
pas parlé plus haut alors lundi alors hk
de bourrache quatre coups responsables
comme responsable oui car coup de pions
cinq responsables également tentant de
faire une forteresse la wii c'est de
bloquer des blancs l'a empêchée
d'avancer beaucoup d'attentes coda tente
parce que six tours 17 maintenant tourin
baisser sa langue
je pense que l'idée doit être ça ainsi
tour bessette là maintenant que le 17ème
jour où j'aurai mon dessin et la cnda
campion et les plateaux puis bouger
enfin on est obligé de
champion des cinq tours ne peut bouger
le coup qu'on peut envisager c'est un
coup droit hors des huit on peut pas
jouer autour des buts on peut jouer en
co 2 oui alors on peut jouer pour des
débits tu n'as pas l'air terrible
puisque après on va piquer m6 en force
penser parce qu'aucun des sept et plus
attaque mallard là beaucoup comme tour
c6 par exemple mais
pour un v6 est patent 7 dans ce cas là
peut-être les noirs maintenant parce que
c'est très facile que tombe la partie en
pointe les blancs veulent troquer leurs
pions bessette contre un autre pion noir
et dernier après et surtout changer une
tour ou passage et en plus oui oui c'est
à dire que l'idée c'est quand on échange
des 7 contre éventuellement devant m6 à
bout des seins et ensuite on passe le
roi lundi à consacrer si ces moyens
combiné ferrer pour être cette eau-là
tour j'ai un échec
cette brave 500 a passé voilà voilà
mais on a donné le ton en v 7 alors
évidemment morozevich lepron puisqu'il
dépend la randonnée mannheim tour en
moins à une torah mois il va gagner plus
on va voir en fait il ya plusieurs
facteurs qui font que ça gagne c'est
matériel d'abord gens mais surtout
l'activité du roi ouais voilà le roi est
très agressif ray très très important de
regarder le rachète fait pitié commun
donc ici à priori c'est une leçon aux
fraises
ça a été transformé essai transformé
tomber trois attaquants pions f4 réside
peut-être tour j'ai trouvé tout
envisageable également tourage trois
peut-être c'est sa seule chance c'est
dans cette position je voulais je sais
pas un retour j'ai trois cylindres très
fort puisque après 11 jours maintenant
mon mais a priori bladi cela vous savez
- peut-être déjà directement commencé à
lesterlin tour h3 f5 il utilise ses
pions c'est pas mal tour pointe quatre
voies la totale du contrat familia du
paquet là il a été obligé d'aller
chercher ce point maintenant au moins
pour avoir un pion passé tour age 2 on
pique dessin donc d'un s'allier et à ce
moment là moi je
on va dire que je pensais que ça allait
être nulle d'options comme ça c'est
assez épineux comme problème puisque la
tour pleut en jouant sur ces trois cases
la versoix et chaque sous attaque un
pion en l'empêchant d'avancer ouais mec
je savais pas trop mais bon là le 25
tirs quand même pourtant si laurent nord
consiste à couper un baiser hymne à se
faire mater une race peut-être de
stockage pour ce que hcap à mon avis la
fraîche quelqu'un de chance parce que
enfin bon je sais c'est compliqué c'est
très compliqué ouais dont j'ai 4 h 3
torje 3g 3 à la rejouer en ferme
en fermant fait le tournoi en fait
maintenant il va simplement
il regarde avec sa tour le contact de
kyo h3 ils empêchent la tour de
s'activer le roi noir lui complètement
bloquée sur le bord et il a plus qu à
pousser son roi et son pion des insultes
qui poussera le pion f dans une position
gagnante et puis c'est fini mais tout
simplement
donc il va avancer son roi jusqu'à 8
polonais ont lancé voilà le plan d'un
comme si c'est le cas et six mois là
l'autre va être obligé van laecke
évidemment je prends avec un chien
croisé ci et de là thomson important
faut couper le roi oui alors il a joué
droit ces cinq d'abord on sait
simplement que pas le couper tout de
suite alors et maintenant tour 3 voilà
norma et couple et ça c'est important
c'est important c'est la position on va
arriver dans la position de loin le pont
- le pompon c'est bien il faudrait poser
le découper en fait il faudrait pouvoir
mettre cette tour en 1 8es leroy f 7
oui c'est ça les noirs sont vraiment
très très loin de cette position donc on
va arriver au fameux pont de l'ue sénat
oui c'est dire qu'on peut pas éviter que
le roi et le pion n'avance que le tueur
surtout en 17 et là c'est gagnant
facilement va regarder la partie oui
il a joué l'otan un nom des cinq de pion
à va il prend ça comment l'arrêter
ces trois là c'est très important parce
qu'il est un pas suffisamment d espace
avec sa tour pour donner des échecs
oui donc s'exécuter techniques ins et
c'était de l'autre côté c'est moins
clair contre des vous à regarder s'il y
avait plus de chance je ne le renie en
cours à six mois ces sept moines en
robes et six attaques la tour et peut
plus donner trop cher évidemment donc la
ville abandonnée qu'est ce qu'il refuse
toujours tour 17
au nom de il n'ya pas d'autre qu'aux
toute façon c'est pas bien même si tours
faudrait du tour à tour un des six mois
là pour un deal avec à progresser le
tout est de toute façon est de montrer
la fin on va montrer quelques coups ont
peut-être montré le transfert d'armes il
faut faire une chaîne le roi vient
devant le pion à empêcher des échelles
le rectorat non si le roi montons f6
pour empêcher justement le fameux pont
bonjour ou en huit ans la vie celui des
options avant cela s'est terminé 3e
dans cette position conjointe au tour 4
et bientôt il faudrait que la tour ici
ici alors voyant qu'est ce qui se passe
ça c'est marrant parce que ça c'est la
position que s'il attend encore mois la
sec en échec au roi des chèques
oui le roi peut pas aller en russie ce
parce qu'il roulait vite
oui laurent viala et maintenant on sort
maintenant soit 11,7 en cette menace
faire dame faut faire échec échec mois
en d6 et sa échec encore roi en os 6
voilà donc on continue d'aller au
quotidien au niveau des disques les
menaces vont être maintenant simplement
touré 5 pour des cinq par là où il ya
beaucoup de menaces on continue les
échecs et maintenant le roi viendront
dessin qui voilà ça c'est précis et
c'est là qu'on voit après l'échec ici
que c'est important que la tour sur la
quatrième manche et puisqu'on la voit là
aux invalides et c'est le fameux pont le
pont de l'ue sénat d'un diagonale de son
numéro quand le sénat quand même il faut
le faire il faut le faire alors on a vu
dans be more as déjà oui c'est pas mal
non milliards au 9 dans les deux sens il
ya déjà aussi tout les ans pour
apprendre à jouer du sénat c'est petit
et il a vite
l'aviron a commenté donc en gros si
c'est possible voilà voilà
merci les appariements un nom de qualif
man c'est je pense le match offert l'un
des matches phares on inventerait un
pronostic justement olivier puisque tu
es notre invité mois le champion du
monde donne à nantes
le champion du monde le sait le champion
du monde mais donald 1-2 vraiment de
c'est un match très serré très serré
c'est peut-être des semi rapide je pense
qu'un an des plus forts
une minute c'est le match aux fans
voilà donc topalov adams adams adam
quatrième fils du mythique et si je suis
un chef mais très très beau match et
shirov variés serré on va dire parce que
marié font les miens ont la rencontre
avec des bonds shirov on espère au
chinois on espère finir on espère shirov
moi je suis pas mal mais ce qui serait
une belle finale ce serait comme
schirrhoffen en demi c'est vraiment
cherché non ça serait une très très
belle finale mais on n'en voit et on se
dit à lundi pour la suite la haine vite
que ça se qualifie rapidement